نبقى مشاهدينا في المشهد السوداني حيث
الاشتباكات مستمره رغم بعض الهدوء في عدد
من احياء العاصمه الخرطوم دون اطلاق نار
ودوي اطلاق نار كثيف كما وتصاعدت اعمده
الدخان في محيط القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه بالخرطوم هذا وقال الجيش السوداني
انه سيطر على مقر قياده الدعم السريع وذلك
في وقت يشهد فيه محيط مطار الخرطوم اطلاق
نار كثيف وتصاعد اعمده الدخان وفي مروي
افاد مراسل عربيه نقلا عن مصادر عسكريه
ببصل جيش السوداني السيطره الكامله على
المطار والقاعده الجويه في مالوي
مبروك يا معلم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وافادت مصادر في الجيش السوداني بان
العمليه العسكريه العسكريه ستاخذ اكثر من
اسبوع بسبب انتشار المتمردين في مجموعات
صغيره وسط الخرطوم واضافت المصادر بان
العمليه العسكريه تهدف الى انهاء عمليات
التمرد كليا ولا يوجد اي حوار او تفاهم
قبل الاستسلام كما قالت المصادر ان
المتمردين فقدوا مراكز الاتصال المركزيه
ويتصرفون كووحدات منفصله في العاصمه
السودانيه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
لعمليات
المواجهه التي ما زالت مستمره منذ بدء هذا
الصراع بين كل من قوه الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني طبعا افادنا مراسلون قبل قليل عن
اشتداد حده هذه المواجهه كما نسمع يعني
اصوات اطلاق النار الكثيفه ما زالت
مستمره
وطبعا كما افادنا الزملاء ايضا بان عمليه
المواجهه تتم عبر
مجموعات صغيره نحن نتحدث عن حرب شوارع
دائره بين كل من قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني هي متوزعه بعدد كبير من المناطق
ومن النقاط ما يعني طبعا
امتداد واستمرار العمليات العسكريه لوقت
اطول مما كان متوقع سنستمع لبعض يعني
للصوت الطبيعي للاشتباكات واعود
اذا مشاهدينا كما نتابع بهذه الصور
للحرائق المستمره في مستودعات لوقود طيران
هذه الصور الحصريه لقناه العربيه عن
عمليات يعني عن الحرائق التي ما زالت
مستمره كنا قد شاهدناها طيله الساعات
الماضيه وهي ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه
الساعه وطبعا مع استمرار عمليات المواجهه
الدائره بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني ما زالت اصوات النار كثيفه وطبعا
الهدنه التي كان قد اتفق عليها بسعه
الماضيه فشلت
بتحقيق او بما كان يعني موعود به الشعب
السوداني
بالساعات الماضيه بسبب عدم التزام الطرفين
بها سينضم الي مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي من مروى الحديث اكثر عن
التطورات الاخيره على الارض نزار كنت قد
افدتنا بالرسائل الماضيه عن السيطره
الكامله للجيش السوداني على القاعده
العسكريه او على مطار مروي هل من تحديدات
جديده حول هذا الموضوع
الامور في على مكانه عليك خلال الساعه
الماضيه
انتشار اضافي لقوات الجيش السوداني في
محيط قاعده مروي العسكريه الجويه
بعد ان خرجت قوات الدعم السريع نتيجه
للاشتباكات المتواصله مع القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الان هنالك حاله من الهدوء
والهدوء الحذر في مدينه مروي والمناطق
المحيطه بها
ليس من جديد حول طبيعه الطريقه التي خرجت
بها القوات والاليه التي خرجت بها قوات
الدعم السريع لكن المؤكد بان الجيش
السوداني الان القوات المسلحه السودانيه
هي من يسيطر هي من يمسك بزمام الامور داخل
القاعده وتدخل الدولي هل هناك من تخوف
لعوده قوات الدعم السريع يعني وشن هجوم
مضاد جديد خصوصا وان هناك بعض التحليلات
يعني تذهب نحو اعاده لملم صفوف القوات
وممكن ان تعاود الهجوم على هذه القاعده
بحسب كثيرين هذا الامر يمكن ان ياتي في
اطار التوقع لكن ما نلاحظه ونشهده بان
الجيش السوداني الان القوات المسلحه
وتنتشر في اكثر من موقع وهي بطبيعه وجودها
هنا في منطقه مروي كانت قد احاطت
مقر القاعده الجويه في مختلف المناطق وفي
مختلف المحاور هذا يعني بان الامتدادات
للجيش هذه تعذب بمجموعات اضافيه قد تصل
الى مروي من مختلف الوحدات العسكريه سواء
كان من مدينه عبره جنوبا او من مدينه شندي
جنوب
المؤكد بان الوضعيه التي كانت فيها قاعده
مروي العسكريه الجويه خلال الاربعه ايام
الماضيه قد تغيرت الان بفعل سيطرت الجيش
عليها وهذا معطى جديد وهذا معطى يضاف الى
التطورات العسكريه التي حدث ت خلال
الساعات الماضيه هل بهذه السيطره يتساءل
كثيرون هل انتهت الان العمليه العسكريه في
مروي هذا هو تساؤل الان مطروح
والدعم السريع
القوات الدعم السريع بهذه هل يعني بالرغم
من انسحاب من القاعده او من مطار مروي هل
يعني رصد اي استقدام لقوات من مناطق اخرى
الى هذه المنطقه
لم نلاحظ ذلك
العسكريه هذا الامر فقط هم اكدوا واشاروا
بان هذه القوات خرجت من القاعده واتجهت في
اتجاهات مختلفه لو سمحت نحن نتابع الان
مباشره على الهواء الصور الاوليه التي
نشرت لدخول قوات الجيش السوداني الى مطار
وقاعده مروي التي نتحدث عنها وهي طبعا هو
المطار الذي يعتبر نقطه صراع استراتيجيه
بين الطرفين بسبب وجود الطائرات العسكريه
وبسبب اهميه اهميه هذا المطار اضافه الى
مطارين اخرين من ضمنهما مطار
الخرطوم يعني هذه المطارات نتحدث عن ثلاث
مطارات رئيسيه
للسيطره سيطره القوات العسكريه هناك عند
بدء
الصراع بين الطرفين دخلت قوات الدعم
السريع الى هذه الى هذه النقطه تحديدا
والى هذا المطار تحديدا كما تحدثت نزار
انقلبت الصوره بساعات الماضيه مع دخول
الجيش السوداني الى هناك مع ما يعنيه من
سيطره استراتيجيه على هذا المطر
بالتاكيد هذا ما اكدنا عليه وهذا ما تم
التاكيد عليه خلال الساعات الماضيه عبر
المعلومات التي تحصلنا عليها وقلنا بانها
معلومات اوليه سنحاول ان نتاكد بالفعل
تاكدنا من هذه المعلومات وكما اشرنا ايضا
بان الواقع الان تغيرت وهذا معطى جديد
ربما يفتح الباب امام سيناريوهات مختلفه
اذا ما تم حسني مروي فان الان ستتجه الى
مناطق اخرى هكذا يرى كثير من يتابع ومن
يحلل هذه العمليه العسكريه التي تمضي في
يومها الثانيه المواطنون هنا في مروي اضيف
بعض الاشارات بانهم يتفاعلون مع كل خطوه
من خطوات هذه العمليه العسكريه لكنهم
يؤكدون حسب الافادات وحسب ما يقولون على
ضروره ان يظل المواطن بعيد عن اي اضرار ان
يظل المواطن بعيد عن اي تاثيرات يمكن ان
تنجم من تمدد العمليات العسكريه سواء
انخفاض
نسبه وجود الغذاء في المناطق التي يعيش
فيها المواطنون انقطاع خدمه الاتصالات
انقطاع خدمات الانترنت اغلاق الطرق كل هذه
الاشياء يحذر منها المواطنون
ويتخوفون لكن يبدو ان الامور الان تتجه
نحو التهدئه بعد ان اكد الجيش السوداني
بانه حسم امر القاعده العملياتيه هنا في
مدينه مروي
بعد حسم العمليه العسكريه بهذه القاعده
بالمنطقه المحيطه هل هناك يعني مواجهات
دائره وباي نقاط
ليس الان من مواجهات بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع بعد ان خرجت لكن بعض
القاده العسكريين هنا
يحذرون المواطنين اطلقوا بعد التحذيرات من
ان القوات التي خرجت من هذه القاعده يمكن
ان تشتبك مع مواطنين في قرى في مناطق وهي
تنتشر بعيدا جاءت هذه التحذيرات على سبيل
ان يتخذ المواطنون الحذر والحيطه وان
يتعاملوا بحذر مع كل سياره او سياره دفع
رباعي تخترق القرى وتخترق الاوديه وهي
الان تستجب في اتجاهات مختلفه بعد ان خرجت
عصر هذا اليوم من القاعده الجويه
نزار الحاله الانسانيه للناس
سم المعركه بهذا المطار هل ممكن ان تكون
يعني افضل من الساعات الماضيه
بالتاكيد المؤشرات تمضي نحو عوده الحياه
الى طبيعتها خاصه بعد ورود هذه الاخبار
الصباح امس وظهر امس وعصر امس ومساء امس
كانت الاجواء متوتره للغايه هنا في مدينه
مروي وفي مدينه كريمه المدينه المجاوره
لمدينه مروي حتى حركه المواطنين مساء يوم
الامس كانت غائبه كانوا يتجمهرون في
المقاهي وفي الساحه العامه اختفت هذه
المظاهر المجتمعيه منذ اليوم وربما يوم
الغد ستعود الامور الى طبيعتها بعد ان
هدات اصوات الرصاص والتبادل اطلاق النار
قد يعود السوق الرئيس هنا في مروي الى فتح
ابوابه وفتح الاسواق وفتح المحاله
التجاريه قد تعود ايضا المؤسسات الرسميه
الى العمل هذه الامور كلها وارده بعد ان
هدات هذه العمليه العسكريه التي كانت مروي
مسرح الرئيس لها
اذا نزار ساعود اليك خلال هذه التغطيه
ابقى معنا لو سمحت مشاهدينا سنكمل واياكم
هذه التغطيه المباشره
للعمليات الدائره بين كل من قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني المواجهات طبعا ما
زالت مستمره بعدد من المناطق ان كان داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم وان كان بمناطق اخرى بعد
حسم مطار ومعركه منطقه مروي التي كانت
فتيل الذي اشعل هذا هذه المواجهه بين
الطرفين التي ما زالت دائره طبعا حتى هذه
الساعه
نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي
التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه لشرك لشركه
ماكسر والتي تظهر الدمار الذي حل في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم جراء
الاشتباكات حيث تظهر الصور في جسور
الخرطوم والمطار والاضرار التي لحقت بمبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
اذا هذه الصور
للدمار الذي
لحق بالمطار
جراء الاشتباكات اليوم بين كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني صور اقمار
اصطناعيه التقطتها شركه ماكسير
ونستعرضها الان
لتبيان حجم الدمار الذي لحق في المطار
وطبعا الجسور المؤديه الى المطار ومبنى
القياده العامه الذي تضرر كثيرا وطبعا عدد
من الطائرات دمرت بالكامل كما نشاهد هنا
منها الطائره التابعه للامم المتحده ومنها
طيارات تابعه
لشركات خاصه طبعا ايضا المواجهات ما زالت
مستمره بمحيط المطار
بالمنطقه الشرقيه للمطار حتى الساعه بين
كل من قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
لمحاوله احكام السيطره على هذا المطار
طبعا منذ بد العمليه العسكريه كانت هناك
محاولات للسيطره على ثلاث نقاط استراتيجيه
منها مطار مروي مطار الخرطوم ومطار الابيض
حسم الصراع في مطار مروي لصالح الجيش
السوداني في مطر الخرطوم مازال مستمر حتى
الساعه وطبعا يعني تعتبر هذه النقاط نقاط
استراتيجيه لان السيطره على المرافق
الاساسيه التي تعتبر
مراكز طيران عسكريه وايضا مدنيه هي اساسيه
بهذا الصراع الا انها طبعا حسمت بمطار
واحد ومطار الخرطوم ما زالت مستمره فيها
حتى الساعه
طبعا مطار الخرطوم له اهميه استراتيجيه
بما انه يشكل منفذ لمرور
95% من حركه الطيران الخارجيه وبالتالي في
حال احكمت قوه الدفع السريع السيطره عليه
تكون قد احكمت السيطره على المنفذ الاساسي
لحركه الدخول والخروج الى العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم والى البلاد بالمجمل
يعتبر طبعا المطار الحالي
يعني المنطقه التي يقع فيها المطار هي ضمن
المناطق السكنيه ومن هنا تكمن خطوره
وصعوبه حسم المعركه ومن هنا يعني استحاله
استخدام الطيران بهذه المعركه وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث فقط عن مواجهات مباشره كحرب
الشوارع
لقوات من الجيش ومن الدعم السريع مما
يساعد طبعا مهمه حسم هذه العمليه العسكريه
بسرعه لصالح طرف على حساب طرف اخر هناك
كثافه سكانيه كبيره حول هذا المطار ومن
هنا يعني كنا تحدثنا عن الوضع الانساني
الصعب للمواطنين هناك بسبب صعوبه الدخول
والخروج بظل الاشتباكات
الحاميه الدائره بين الطرفين
اذا ايضا مطار الخرطوم للتفكير مشاهدينا
بانه بالرغم من انه مطار مدني يعني في
ظاهره الا انه ايضا يعتبر قاعده جويه
كبيره للقوات
السودانيه ومن هنا يعني محاوله محاوله
قوات الدعم السريع فور بدا هذه العمليه
والمناوشات بين الطرفين
ذهبت الى مطار مروي الى مطار الخرطوم
وطبعا مطار الابيض للسيطره على القواعد
الاساسيه وشل حركه الجيش السوداني اعود
مشاهدينا الى صور من مطار الخرطوم بما
اننا نتحدث عنه الصور الاوليه للدمار الذي
لحق هذا المطار نحن نتحدث عن يعني فقط
ساعات لبدء الاشتباك بين الطرفين
والصور تظهر دمار كبير بالجسور المؤديه
للمطار
بالمبنى الرئيسي مبنى القياده العامه للم
طار وطبعا طائرات مدنيه
وعسكريه وايضا المبنى العامه مبنى القوات
العسكريه ايضا نتضرر بشكل كبير مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات العسكريه الموجود
داخل مطار الخرطوم
انتقل مشاهدينا الى القاهره والاستاذه
عطيه العيساوي الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه بمركز الاهرام استاذ يعني عندما
اتحدث عن قائدي هذه العمليه العسكريه
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني اتحدث عن
البرهان ودجلو الذين تعود العلاقه بينهما
الى اكثر من عقدين من الزمن منذ دارفور
وحتى اليوم وبالتالي نتحدث عن قائدين
يعرفان بعضهما يعني عز المعرفه ويعرفان
قدرات الطرف الاخر ايضا عز المعرفه هل
ممكن لهذه النقطه ان تكون يعني نقطه سلبيه
بمسار المعارك وان تصعد مسار المعارك
وتطيل ام ماذا اكثر
بالتاكيد هما يعرفان بعضهما جيدا ولكن
يعني
الانفه
والشعور
بالعزه وتضخم
السلطه ربما انتاب احدهما او كليهما
وبالتالي لم يطق
كل منهما ان يصبر على الاخر حتى يتم حل
الخلاف
سلميا عن طريق التفاوض لكن طبعا
ادى ذلك الى هذا الانفجار الذي حدث عندما
حرك
قائد الدعم السريع قوته
عفوا انا يجب الا اسميهم قوات وانما
افراد عندما حرك افراده من
مناطق اخرى مثل دارفور الى مروي والى
الخرطوم ليحشد في مواجهه
القوات الجيش فهذا استفز قائد الجيش
لانه يجب كل حركه يجب ان تتم بالتنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه وليس هو
سريع بالت سميه
حتى نشرع
تسميه ليس بالشيء الجديد
عفوا يعني انا اقول ليست قوات لانها هي
ميليشيا تم ضمها
او تم استخدامها لمسانده قوات الجيش وليست
قوات
مسلحه حقيقيه
نتحدث عن التسميه هي تسميه هي تسميه على
اطيب لها عند ضمه الى القوه لذلك
عفوا بمعزل
عن هدى عند الطرفين اليوم هل يمكن ان تكسر
بمسار المعارك على الارض او ان يتنازل اي
طرف للطرف الاخر
لن يتنازل اي طرف
للاخر الا اذا شعر انه على وشك ان يخسر
المعركه وبالتالي سيضطر الى المهادنه والى
قبول العروض والمناشدات
باللجوء الى التفاوض بعد وقف اطلاق النار
مؤقتا ولكن اذا استمر كل منهما يشعر
بالقوه
في مواجهه الاخر وبانه باستطاعته ان يحسم
القضيه لصالحه او المعركه لصالحه فسوف
تستمر هذه
المعارك خاصه بعد ان انتشرت او
تفرقت قوات الدعم السريع الى مجموعات
صغيره وفقا للخبر الوارد على شاشه العربيه
هذه القوات ربما تفقد عفوا هذه الافراد
هؤلاء هذه المجموعات ربما تفقد الاتصال
الرئيسيه وبالتالي
وربما يكون تكتيك يعني
بحرب الشوارع هناك تكتيك
عسكري
بان تكون يعني مجموعات صغيره وبالتالي
تقليل الخسائر البشريه في حال تم يعني
كانت المواجهات
ضاريه بين المجموعات ابقى معي لو سمحت
استاذ ايضا يمكن ان يكون عفوا يمكن ان
يكون تكتيكا ويمكن ان يكون قد فقدوا
الاتصال بالفعل بعد ضرب العربه العربه
الرئيسيه الخاصه بالاتصالات بين قوات
الدعم السريع
ساعود اليك استاذ ابقى
معي مشاهدينا هنا ساذكر بانه تضررت مكاتب
قناتي العربيه والحدث في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بعد وقوع قصف جوي طالع
ابراج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب العربيه
والحدث دون وقوع اي اصابات اذا هذه هي
الصور الاوليه
لتضرر مكاتب العربيه والحدث بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بعد عمليه القصف الجوي
الذي تعرض له المبنى حيث يعني موجودين
المكاتب مكاتب قناتي العربيه والحدث
اذا مشاهدينا اعيد واذكر بان هذه هي الصور
الاوليه لتضرر مكتبي العربيه والحدث في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بعد قصف جوي
طال ابراج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب العربيه
والحدث دون وقوع اي اصابات
الصوت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
من الخرطوم مشاهدينا معنا مرسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي سالم كنا نستعرض عمليات
الدمار الكبيره التي لحقت بمطار الخرطوم
وايضا يعني نرصد المواجهات التي ما زالت
مستمره في شوارع الخرطوم بين الطرفين
الدعم السريع والجيش هل من تحديثات جديده
حول العمليات الدائره حول المطار الذي
يعتبر نقطه مهمه اليوم لكلا الطرفين
نعم ما زالت الامور كما هي عليه الان
تتجدد الاشتباكات بين الفينه والاخرى ثم
بعد ذلك تبدا في انخفض مستوىها الى ان
مستوى ثم تتجدد مره اخرى بهذا الشكل خلال
هذا اليوم في مطار الخرطوم ومحيط مطار
الخرطوم وهناك مناطق من مطار الخرطوم
تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريع وهناك
مناطق اخرى يسيطر عليها الجيش السوداني
وعليها اشتباك بين الجنس السوداني والدعم
السريع فيما يتعلق بالقياده العامه للجيش
السوداني
هذه الاشتباكات يعني
حدث فيها الكثير من
القصف بالمدفعيات وكذلك
يعني استخدام اسلحه ثقيله جدا تضررت منها
النظامي القياده العامه تضرر منها المطار
وربما الضرر الاكبر حتى الان في نظر
العديد من المتابعين
[موسيقى]
الجيش هذا الامر او العكس كذلك
هذه هي ايضا الاعلاميه اليوم
على الارض سالم لو سمحت المطار الثالث
الموجود في ولايه شمال كردفان في الغربيه
البلاد
يسالوا بيض هل من تحديثات حول ماذا يجري
هناك
نعم لا يوجد تحديثات اخر تحديثات
والمعلومات التي لدينا هي الحديث الذي
تحدث عنه قائد قوات الدعم السرير محمد
حمدان
حينما تحدث عن سيطرتهم على مطار الابيض
وايضا مطار مروري
ومطار تحدث عن هذه الثلاث مطارات بالتحديد
واضاف اليها القاعده الجويه في جبل
الاوليه القاعده الجويه في جبل الاوليه
بحسب معلوماتنا تسيطر عليها القوات
المسلحه الان
ولا يوجد الدعم السريع في هذه القاعده
القاعده الجويه التابعه
للقوات المسلحه في منطقه جبل اولياء جنوبي
الخرطوم مطار الابيض لا تحديثات حول هذا
الموضوع
ايضا
جاءنا في من القوات المسلحه لكن رسميا
وانما من محللين
يحسبون على
القوات المسلحه وهم يدافعون عنها يتحدثون
على المطار الاوبي لمسيطره عليه وكذا لكن
لم ياتينا في رسمي من الجيش السوداني عن
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع على مطار ان ابين
يعني من اي اخبار من
القوات الامم المتحده لحفظ السلام خصوصا
بان هذا المطار يعتبر مركز لها هناك
نعم هو بالنسبه
المنظمات العامله كان هناك اعتداء في
دارفور في الفاشر اعتداء على احدى
المنظمات ومقتل افرادها على يد عدد من
افرادها على يد قوات الدعم السريع وقد
ناشدت المجتمع الدولي بالتدخل لانه هذا
اعتدال يعتبر سافر على هذه المنظمات وعلى
عملها في تلك المناطق
فالان بعد ان اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته
على مطار في الولايه الشماليه وهذه
المعركه المحترمه الان في مطار الخرطوم
وهو
المطار الاهم الان وهي المنطقه الاهم
لانها تحوي مطار الخرطوم والقياده العامه
للجيش ولا تبعد كثيرا عن القصر الجمهوري
نهايه هذه المعركه والقدره على السيطره
على هذه المعركه ربما تحدد مصير الطرف
الذي يسيطر المنطقه
يعني
بالارقام او بالمعطيات الموجوده على الارض
لمن يعني اليوم تميل كافه
السيطره الاسرع او
الكامله على هذه المنطقه بالساعات المقبله
صعب جدا التكهن لمن ستكون الغلبه او من
سيسيطر لكن الجيش السوداني بالامس كان قد
استطاع ان يعلن ان
واحد من المعسكرات الكبيره لقوات الدعم
السريع اعلن انه سيطر عليها وهو معسكر اخر
اتصال ايضا من المعسكرات الكبيره لاخوات
الدعم السريع اعلنت كذلك انه قصفه قصف
ثقيلا بالطيران ليلى البارحه
واليوم يعلن عن ان مطار منوي اصبح ايضا
تحت اداره الجيش السوداني هذه هي
الاشتباكات الان تتجدد هنا في الخرطوم هذه
المنطقه بالتحديد منطقه القياده العامه
للجيش ومطار الخرطوم سالم يعني كنت اسال
الزميل بمنطقه مروي
ساعود واسال السؤال نفسه ولكن عن الخرطوم
على
ما فالنستمع الى الاشتباكات واعود اليك
سالم
اذا مشاهدينا نستمع الى
الاشتباكات التي
ما زالت دائره بين كل من قوات الدعم
السريع وطبعا
الجيش السوداني اذا تجدد الاشتباكات في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني والتي
هي يعني مستمره منذ بدء هذا الصراع بين
الطرفين لمحاوله السيطره على النقاط
الاساسيه
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
كما نسمع وكما يوافينا الزملاء هناك بهذه
الصور الخاصه والحصريه للعربيه اصوات
قذائف
واسلحه ثقيله بهذه الاثناء
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
بتستخدم في المواجهات الدائره بين قوات
الدعم السريع بقياده دقلو والجيش السوداني
بقياده البرهان
اكد مشاهدينا رئيس حزب الامه القوميه
السودانيه فضل الله ناصر في تصريحات
للعربيه انه غير قادر حتى اللحظه على
التواصل مع رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو ودعا فضل الله البرهان لفتح
خطوط هواتفهما حتى تستطيع القوى السياسيه
التواصل معهما
في سياق ايضا متصل قال رئيس الوزراء
السودانيه السابق عبد الله حمدوك ان الوضع
الانساني كارثي مشيرا الى ان المعاناه
تفاقمت بسبب الاشتباكات الحاصله بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه
اذا فلنستمع الى ما قاله حمدوك
نلتقي في ظرف
اصيب وضع
يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
انه وضع كارثي
قنا اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلتني داء
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
ان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
اعد مشاهدينا الى هذه الصور المباشره
للمواجهات الدائره والتي كما ذكرنا تستخدم
فيها الاسلحه الثقيله من قذائف
وغيرها فلنستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي واعود
اعد مشاهدينا الى الزميل سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم سالم نحن نتابع
هذه الاشتباكات الليليه بين قوات الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في الخرطوم
وتحديدا بمحيط القياده العامه يعني ما هي
اخر التحديثات حول هذه العمليات
وما الاسلحه المستخدمه هناك يعني نحن
نتحدث عن اسلحه ثقيله هل هناك تغيير
بالاسلحه المستخدمه ام انها ما زالت نفسها
لعم هذه هي الاسلحه من
ذ
الاشتباسات وهذه المعركه او هذه الحرب
منها مثلا من الاسلحه الثقيله الطيران
كذلك القاذفات
اشكالها وانواعها كذلك يتم استخدام كل هذه
المقذوفات بانواعها
الهاون كذلك كل هذه الاصناف من السلاح
الثقيله يتم استخدامها في هذه الحرب ايضا
هناك
مساله الاستخدام الطيران كذلك يستخدمه
الجيش السوداني لان قوات الدعم السريع لا
تمتلك الطيران الطيران يمتلكم الجيش
السوداني استخدم في هذه الحرب الطائرات
وكذلك المروحيات المقاتله وغيرها من
الاسلحه الثقيله التي استخدمت في هذه
الحرب حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني بحيز محدود جدا بسبب تواجد الكثيف
للمدنيين بالن التي يدور فيها الصراع في
الساعات الماضيه وحتى المطار يعني هو
موجود ايضا هناك اقتضاع سكاني بمحيط هذا
المطر سالم ابقى معي لو سمحت سنعود اليك
طبعا خلال هذه التغطيه
وما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره في من
العاصمه الخرطوم لعمليات المواجهه الدائره
الان مشاهدينا ينضم الي في الاستوديو
الدكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى الكاتب
والمحلل في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا بك
دكتور يعني هناك نقطه ساتحدث عنها بظل هذا
الصراع الدائر بان حتى يعني ان كنا نتحدث
عن صراع نفوذ وموجود بين البرهان ولكن
هناك خوف لدى دوجلو خوف وجود بانه في حال
كان هناك عمليه دمج قبل العمليه
الانتقاليه والمسار ممكن ان يتم التضحيه
به ونحن نتحدث عن ان لديه ملفات حقوق
انسان وغيره وهو مطلوب للجنائيه الدوليه
هل هذه النقطه لن تسمح له بالتراجع مهما
كلف الامر اليوم في الشارع وفي المواجهات
مصيب كلامك تماما في هذا الجزء بالتحديد
خاصه هنالك يشير لانه
سمت قرار من
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه قد يصدر في
الخلايا الايام القادمه بشان
محمدان
ومجموعته يعني لاننا يعني
اساسي وكنا نتحدث مع الزملاء لماذا
ان يكون
شيء لا يفسر غير هذا الموضوع بانه خائف من
ان يتم التضحيه به قبل الوصول الى المسار
الانتقالي الحقيقي هذه واحده من
يعني الفرضيات الفرضيه الثانيه اللي هي
محاوله
يعني
البرهان في الفتره الاخيره خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين
كثير صرح
واجتمع بالقوات العسكريه واجتمع بهم وحاول
ان يبين
العسكريين التابعين للقوات الشعب المسلحه
بانه
التيار الاخر قوات الدعم السريع ليست هي
القوات التي يجب ان تكون موازيه لها
باعتبار انه قوات الشعب المسله هي القوات
الاساسيه للدوله بالرغم من انه انضمام
قوات حركه من مجموعه
الدعم السريع بشكل مباشر هي تابعه للقوات
المسلحه او وفق القرار رقم خمسه
موجوده الى جانب القوات المسلحه بالرغم من
انه البند الخامس في فتره من الفترات في
2019 بعد الثوره سحب من من قانون الدعم
السريع ولكن من السحب القرار حتى الان غير
معروف هل بهذه النقطه تحديدا ايضا من
النقاط الخلافيه التي حكي عنها بعمليه
الدمج ليس فقط التوقيت وانما ايضا عمليه
رتب الضباط وكيفيه دمج داخل العسكر
ومحاوله تهميش كما تحدث هذه النقطه ايضا
الى اي مدى جعلت يعني عمليه الدعم المعنوي
او اذا صح التعبير
النزول الى الشارع اسرع لقوات الدعم نعم
قوات الدعم بما فيهم رئيس
هو لم يتخرج من الكليه الحربيه وهنالك
اساس المواقف حاده من بعض القوات يعني
مباشره
نتحدث عن الكبا على سبيل المثال الفريق
الكرباشي لن يقبل بشكل مباشر
انه محمد حمدان دوبل يكون احد القاده ولكن
ضمنيا كسب هذا الامر وسكت به
وبالتالي محمد حمدان بينه وبين نفسه يعرف
انه هو ليس ذلك كفؤ لهذا المشهد ولكن
قواته الكثيره المنتشره في كل بقاع
السودان بالاسلحه التي لديه كان يتحرك
ولكن الواقع الافق لما نصل الى مساله
الافق الحقيقي له
لا بد ان نصل لهذا الوضع نحن فيه باعتبار
انه يوجد محاوله الاستئثار بالسلطه باي
شكل من الاشكال ويكون موجود في السطح
موازنه السيد البرهان الذي هو اخفق
الاثنين لم يختلفان في امر لانهم جميعا
يبحث عن الجلوس على السلطه
المدنيين صراع سلطه
بشعارات عسكريه بشعارات حمايه للامن
القومي السوداني شعارات كثيره ولكن هو
يختصر بصراع سلطه ابقى معي استاذ ساعود
لنستمع الى المواجهات الدائره داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم والتي اشتدت بعد ساعات
الهدنه التي كان قد اعلن عنها والتي طبعا
خلقت ولم تكتمل فلنستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
اذا مشاهدينا هذا ولا تزال تسمع بعض اصوات
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وخوات
الدعم السريع ذلك رغم قبول الطرفين بمقترح
الامم المتحده للتهدئه لساعات وفتح مسارات
امنه للحالات الانسانيه فيما اشار مراسل
العربيه الى عوده تدريجيه للتيار
الكهربائي والمياه لعدد من احياء الخرطوم
بالتزامن مع المهله مهله الطرفان اللذان
اكد احتفاظهما بحق الرد على اي هجوم او
تجاوز هذا واعلنت كل من قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني على موافقتهما على مقترح
الامم المتحده بفتح مسارات امنه للحالات
الانسانيه
تتواصل مشاهدينا الاشتباكات في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويقع مقر القياده العامه في المنطقه
الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه
كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم بينما
يتواجد بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات
البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات الجويه ويعد
مقر القياده العامه مركزا مهما وحساسا
بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني ويستمر
اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع تداول
اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
اعود مشاهدينا الى الصور المباشره
للعمليه العسكريه الدائره بين كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني والتي يحاول
فيها الطرفان احكام السيطره على المناطق
الاساسيه وعلى المرافق الرئيسيه
لطبعا
كسب هذه العمليه العسكريه والمواجهات
الدائره على الارض
اعود مشاهدينا الى الدكتور اسامه احمد
المصطفى الكاتب والمحلل بالشؤون الافريقيه
دكتور اسامه يعني عندما نتحدث عن العلاقه
بين بين يعني من يدير الصراع اليوم على
الارض بين دقلو والبرهان نتحدث عن علاقه
رجلين تعود الى عقدين من الزمن كان حليفين
بعد اسقاط نظام البشير من بعد دخلت
الخلافات الخلافات يعني
الصراع يشتد اكثر على ما يبدو الخلافات هي
ليست خلافات جوهريه على مصلحه البلاد بقدر
ما هي خلافات على السلطه وعلى كيفيه اداره
المرحله المقبله والحفاظ على المكتسبات
التي حققها الطرفين طيله المرحله الماضيه
بعد سقوط نظام البشير اليوم عندما يعني
نرى كل هذه الصوره كيف يمكن ان ينتهي
الصراع بين الرجلين
دعينا اشير لانه الطرفين ليسوا فقط اصبح
في السلطه في ما بعد ازاله البشير في 2019
لا هما منذ دارفور موجودين صحيح صحيح
هنالك ما يسمى بقوه بالواجهه الاساسيه
للسلطه بعد 2014 عندما تم تكوين
قوات الدعم السريع وانضمت الى الامن ثم في
2017 اصبحت ضمن القوات المسلحه
ضمن القوات المسلحه وليست يعني موازيه
للقوات المسلحه اذا
الطرفين الان الصراحه اصبح صراع نفوذ صراع
من ينتصر وبالتاكيد
القوات المسلحه بما لديها من امكانيه يمكن
لوجيستيه وامكانيات اسلحه قويه جدا لم
تستخدمها حتى الان حتى هي تنتصر في
النهايه وفي النهايه عندما ينتصر الطرف هو
البيملي شروطه
وعلى الطرف الاخر وعلى الطرف الاخر ان
يوجد مساحه للتقارب لانه المساله لن تنتهي
بسرعه جدا وبتفاوض حتى وان دخلت الان
الوساطات المحليه والبساطات الاقليميه
وغيرها من الوساطات لا بد من اقتناع
الطرفين بانه المرحله تتطلب الهدنه او
نزعفت الى الازمه من بين ايضا النقاط
الخلافيه ساعود اليك استاذ ولكن اسمح لي
ان انتقل الى صور لاشتباكات اليوم بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع قرب سلاح
المهندسين في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا هذه صور
لاحدى المعارك الموجوده والدائره في عدد
من المناطق داخل العاصمه الخرطوم اتحدث
هنا عن
[تصفيق]
مواجهه بين الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
قربي المهندسين في العاصمه
[موسيقى]
طيب
كلهم
الى العاصمه الخرطوم ومراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي
لنقل الصوره من هناك سالم نحن نتابع الصور
المباشره للمواجهات الدائره بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني عمليات
الحرائق التي لم تهدا هل هي ما زالت
بمحطات الوقود ام انها بمكان اخر
لعمل الحريق الاكبر كان في محطه في مستودع
للوقود
الاكبر في في منطقه
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالزليم
بالزميل سالم الهاشمي
اتابع واياكم اذا مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه
وهذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه الخرطوم
للمواجهات التي ما زالت مستمره بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني
[تصفيق]
والاحزاب للانتخابات دايرين الانتخابات
حره نزيهه
[تصفيق]
التوتر لا يزال سيد الموقف في السودان
خيوط الخلافات بين مكونين عسكري ومدني
فتحت باب التساؤل حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا
التوتر وتقود في نهايتها لمارس الماضي
وخلاف ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
الورشه التي اختتمت حينها وسط غيو بقاده
الجيش شهدت خلافات النشبت بين ضباط الجيش
المشاركين في ختام ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وقاده قوات الدعم السريع ابرز
نقاط الخلاف كان صياغه التوصيات الاخيره
للورشه التي تتطرق لاصلاحات امنيه ابرزها
مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش
وتواريخ الدمج وتفاصيل الرتب حيث طالبت
ورقه الجيش بحصر دمج قوات الدعم السريع
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه التي حددها
الاتفاق الايطالي باربعه وعشرين شهرا ووضع
ترتيبات امنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقعه
على اتفاق جوبا لسلام السودان وفق جدا
الزمنيه محدده كما تحدد ورقه الجيش ضوابط
ومعايير قبول التحاق ضباط قوات الدعم
السريع وتسرح من تم تعيينهم بعد سقوط نظام
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير وتقنين صلاحيات
الدعم السريع العسكريه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه من جهه اخرى الخلاف بين الدعم
السريع والجيش ليس خلافا فنيا حول فتره
دمج قوات الدعم السريع والتي تطالب
الاخيره بان تكون خلال عشر سنوات بل هو
خلاف سياسي بسبب تقاطع مواقف قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميدتي تجاه العمليه السياسيه
والتحالفات المستقبليه خاصه ان الدعم
السريع نص بتوصياته خلال ورشه الاصلاح
الامني على مراجعه وتطوير العقيده
العسكريه وناي المؤسسه العسكريه عن التدخل
في السياسه لكن الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين
العسكريتين اعمق من مجرد اختلاف على عمليه
دمج القوات فمصادر مقربه من البرهان ودجلو
كشفت بانهما مازال على خلاف حول من سيتقلد
منصب القائد العام للجيش خلال فتره
الاندماج التي ستمتد عده سنوات
وفي الاطار الجهود الدوليه للتهدئه اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير الامير
فيصل بن فرحان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا مع رئيس
مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما اجرت اتصالا اخر مع نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده محمد حمدان دقلو واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ضروره التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السودان كما شدد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن للسودان
اذا مشاهدينا باخر العواجل التي وردت عن
الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع تستهدف
مناطق سكنيه داخل العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا
الجيش السوداني يقول بانه يطالب المواطنين
بالحذر من القصف العشوائي للدعم السريع
ايضا الجيش السوداني
نتبع نتبع قواعد الاشتباك المهنيه لمنع
وقوع ضحايا بين المدنيين الجيش السوداني
يقول ايضا بان قوات الدعم السريع تقصف
منشات حيويه في الخرطوم
وطبعا القصف ما زال مستمر والمواجهات ما
زالت مستمره بين الطرفين اذا كانت هذه اخر
التصريحات للجيش السوداني الذي يقول بان
القوات المتبقيه من الدعم السريع تريد نشر
الفوضى والرعب بين المواطنين وبانها تقصف
بشكل عشوائي المناطق المناطق السكنيه كما
كنا قد ذكرنا بان المواجهات الدائره كلها
تقع يعني داخل العاصمه داخل الشوارع
ونتحدث عن شوارع مقتظه بالسكان حتى
العمليه العسكريه الدائره في محيط المطار
مطار الخرطوم هي ايضا بمنطقه سكنيه يحيط
اقتضاض سكاني مما يصعب طبعا مهام الطرفين
للحقول دون ايقاع اصابات بصفوف المدنيه
اذا خلافات بين الطرفين حول الاتفاق
الاطاري ومنتج عنه من عمليه سياسيه خلاف
سياسي ادى الى تطور تطور هذا الموضوع
ويعني نتج عنه مواجهه عسكريه على الارض
طبعا كما كنا قد ذكرنا طيله ساعات التغطيه
الماضيه صراع بين الطرفين على السلطه وعلى
عمليه الدمج وعلى تفاصيل كثيره سياسيه
سياسيه بحث تستخدم فيها اليوم الادوات
العسكريه على الارض لحسم الصراع لمصلحه
طرف واحد خصوصا وان الطرفان المتنازعان
هما طرفان
بالعمليه العسكريه بالوجود العسكري على
الارض
وبالوجود الامني على الارض منذ عقود داخل
السودان
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام هذه الساعه
ساعه التغطيه التغطيه العربيه مستمره
للتطورات في السودان في العاصمه وفي مناطق
اخرى والان الى الزميل طاهر بركه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات